and finally numeral Republicans have to
learn the difference between being
conservative and just being a dick so
much of what they have done since Trump
took over isn't moving the party in a
more conservative direction it's also
not a libertarian move it's just a dick
move take for instance the bizarre
decision to reverse the ban on lead
ammunition for over a decade we've been
moving away from lead bullets because
when a sportsman experiences the
exquisite joy that comes from blowing
the head off a chipmunk or a wolf and
leaves it to rot bald eagles eat the
carcass and when it has led in it it
poisons them to death slowly and
painfully if it doesn't have lead Eagles
you know the symbol of our [ __ ]
country before they were replaced by a
trucker hat
[Applause]
if it doesn't have lead in it they don't
die why not leave that rule alone
because hunting is a sacred sport is it
even really a sport is it a sport if one
team doesn't know the game is going on
we're voters in 2016 asking that we
poison Eagles does it get anyone a job
does it save money does it do anything
conservativism is supposed to be about
no it's just about some warped idea that
the way to show strength is by being a
dick and that in a nutshell is what
republicanism has become looking at any
problem and saying what would a dick
what would a dick do if if there was a
pesticide that was found to impair
cognitive development in children use it
of course last week our new anti EPA EPA
okayed the use of chlorpyrifos which the
Obama administration was in the process
of banning because they had a no
tolerance policy on substances that can
cause brain damage in children but
President Trump says whatever I ate
paint chips as a kid and look at me I is
president but really not even children
in the mix stops you from the prime
directive of being a dick nope
they see a chance to be a dick and they
grab it same way they lost their minds
when Michelle Obama tried to get kids to
eat vegetables vegetables what is this a
high school or a Whole Foods and school
lunch programs that just encourages a
dependency on food no more free ride you
lazy six-year-olds you want to eat you
do what kids and China do so ties for
president Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand or at least I thought I did
Republican principals greed fear racism
sure but why bring back asbestos yeah
asbestos another dick move on their
agenda who the [ __ ] is still in the
corner of biggest bestest in 2017 what
was the last time you heard someone say
yeah we just bought a house can't wait
to move in but not until we install the
asbestos finally what possible reason
other than spite could they have for
killing the agreement Obama made with
the car companies to get all cars up to
an average of 55 miles a gallon in eight
years this was a done deal an industry
that we taxpayers bailed out and is now
making record profits already agreed to
it it makes the air cleaner it makes us
more energy independent it saves people
money that they can spend on other
things it was a win win win win
that's called a no-brainer which would
lead you to believe even Republicans
could get it right all they had to do
was nothing their specialty
but no no no it goes against the prime
directive of let's say it together
being a dead very good they know carbon
is killing the planet they don't care
because the main purpose of a car is to
piss off liberals good gas mileage is
for Europeans and lesbians and a
Republican drives a Chevy Suburban and
always parks it in a space market
compact